[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's Thursday you guys were more than
halfway through I know you know actually
I was in a car yesterday just thinking
to myself wow this week really flew by
by and that feeling of like wow the week
just goodbye
it was so unknown to me it's so hard to
come back I haven't felt that feeling
like I actually remember I had a job me
when I was taken back to the last time I
felt that way and it was when I was an
intern at oh that's crazy it's not crazy
that was when I was in college like wow
I'm just so grateful for this feeling
like I just I know it won't be for a
while still while it's here I want to
say I love you I love you to you we
actually are gonna have a good weekend
because we're both here are you here too
yeah and I think it's gonna be equal
parts relaxing and fun also Claudia and
I are filming our drunk get ready with
us this advantage so inevitably we are
going to be drunk I don't know why I
just like have a bit about it I know but
we'll watch it back the next day and I'm
not anything that I said it's just like
the thought of like remember those me
know when you're about to get so drunk
yes for like seemingly no reason you
just fall into it right and that's just
so fun and carefree but it's like you
ever remember those videos that was that
company that would like make people get
high like those three grandmas getting
high member that video yes I mean that
kind of whole series of like yeah gee
people get high those videos would give
me such like paranoid anxiety and I just
feel like that's what we're doing it's
like an incubator like let's watch
people you know yeah no I think it'll be
fun I just hope I do my makeup well
because we are going out we got to hit
the town with all that energy the the
live stream it's just ablaze with the
fact that you're wearing jeans because
you never we're never real jeans up
until two days ago what I didn't own
jeans this color but I actually am glad
you brought up my jeans because they are
new clearly and they're from Frank and
oak which is a sponsor of the toast that
we talked about earlier this week and I
just wanted to show you guys we're not
spotting they're not sponsoring the show
today but he's wanted to show you like
the quality of stuff and I actually love
it's a subscription box now I sound like
an ad you get in the mail and you get to
pick all this stuff so because I was
getting a bunch of things I kind of
chose some things I might not want
something crazy so I never in my life
would have bought these jeans and now I
am so bad that I have them thanks to
Frank and oak and thanks to the toes
well my shirt is also from a prestigious
retailer called ketosis and Comm been
actually designed these avocado to
t-shirts and
they're hilarious but you can tell that
a man made them because the nipples are
so high up like this is what a pornstar
would wear you know but I feel like
maybe it's creating an illusion then I
have perky tits and I'm actually really
here for no it really is it's like your
tits are a detention my tits are like
deers in headlights just looking
straight at it yeah this is from a March
drop that I'm an a sponsor for my
husband his merch drops today at noon on
ketose season szn calm if you want to
check it out there's actually really
cute high-quality stuff he worked super
hard on it like he's never been so
excited I think he's more excited about
this merch shop and he was like for our
wedding that's sweet
that makes sense also because we both
like hated our wedding that's true I'm
looking forward to your wedding redo you
guys need to read you need you are about
we also need to read you know what's so
funny is there's a wedding store like a
bridal shop right by where he lives so
whenever I walk theoi right walk right
past it it's like a fancy one and I
always like look past the windows I'm
like that's the dress I'm gonna get
whenever you do my photos it's actually
very glamorous like it has a cape and I
just think like KP vibes are definitely
forming something like love my arms you
know oh I like that but is it you trendy
like well I have to redo what my photos
again in five years when capes are not
in trend in style
I feel two ways about trendy dresses
like I'm the one hand it's like you want
your children to look at these photos
and think you were beautiful forever on
the other hand your children aren't
looking at your wedding photos every day
and I'm the other foot it's like it's a
sign of the time yes in the words of
Harry Styles don't stop your crying it's
a sign of the times
also that reminded me of this week's
episode of Real Housewives of Orange
County when Tamra found her wedding
dress it was super cute beautiful
beautiful like timeless timeless which
is actually kind of shocking I I wasn't
expecting that I don't mean either when
she pulled it out I was like oh my god
that's gorgeous in them and they showed
a photo of her 10 years ago wearing it I
was like oh my god she looks gorgeous
then and now yeah it was like high
fashion you know it was like super glam
I think it might be the best she ever
like look no I put that but that's what
it should be
that's true where did her and Eddie get
married on TV yeah no but I know like
where like location-wise at her hotel
I wasn't like an OC like obsessed and I
was in college I guy too much homework
to be watching spin-offs no that's why
Margolis watch Bravo yeah true but I do
love that Bravo is consistent with their
housewife wedding spin-offs like pretty
much everyone gets one except for
Janelle stabbed it separately unlock in
yeah that's true but their Dallas isn't
like enough of a cemented franchise for
them to be just handing
spin-offs but Lian is enough of a
cemented woman he's and he said in an
interview once that his all SWAT
all-star housewives team includes
Leeanne Locken which is so crazy because
she was like the freshest one
she's new on the scene yeah that is
crazy makes you think well we're gonna
recap OSI and southern charm at the end
of the show because I stayed up so late
watching i watch so much TV yesterday
like as homework for this show like and
this morning Taylor Swift on GMA like so
much we're gonna talk about that can't
wait to hear about it and as so many
people are commenting yes today is a
lover day today's love it's so weird but
because tonight is right yeah it was
technically today but I consider it
today and I just have to say I'm very
strong you're strong yeah how so
thank you for asking I came upon
something today I got I got a link in my
inbox and it was a leak of the whole
album on a Google Drive why from he
would like a toaster I can't say and you
did not listen to it don't do it don't
know what because first of all like I
want to have the experience with
everyone like knowing things before
people but not being able to say
anything is like not fun like hello I
knew Ariana and Pete we're engaged cuz I
saw them at a party and I couldn't
[ __ ] say anything and you know what it
wasn't fun I would have rather found out
with everyone else you know yeah um so
it's like having the kind of information
like it's cool but like then after I
feel like after I listen to it I would
have been like upset yeah also like you
need to hear it in the way that Taylor
intended maybe the quality is not gonna
be a hundred percent yeah and it just it
felt icky like if I'm gonna be a real
Stan and like an honest Stan which I am
and I've always said like a part of Stan
culture is like it's being being a good
stance not just being like a blind
leader it's like calling people out when
you think that they've done something
wrong but like in a nice and respectful
way that you're not to just like be
obsessed with someone and think that
everything they do is right and I just
think I wouldn't be like a good honest
stand that that I think that I am if I
listened to some leaky leaky vibes
no but it's kind of like wearing a
knockoff purse like there's something
about it that's not and it actually will
take away from the experience yeah it
feels cheap I remember I got Adele's
late newest album 25 so to die for it
came out so there was some guy at work
we were both working at AOL and some guy
gave it to us yeah and I don't remember
if I wound up listening to it but like I
used to be so OCD about like music that
even when I went down
songs illegally to my itunes I would put
in all the information like album year
songwriters because I wanted it to the
photo and the photo and the photo and
it's like just five a song and by the
way I already bought it so that would
just be like a waste of my money but now
I'm thinking two things one marker we
gotta go to Target I know because I want
a physical copy there's a target in the
city now I'd there's two kids Bay
perfect except I'll get my life that by
the time we get our asses there it'll be
sold out oh no we have to go out of the
city I don't know maybe but if she lives
here and yeah but you know we do have to
do I just did something so smart New
Yorkers are too cool for stuff like I
just put my phone on Do Not Disturb I
don't know I mean never do that for the
toast
I've always get distracted about my
texts I'm gonna you know we need to do
this weekend because we're all here go
to the pop-up shop of course that's what
I really want
probably in Soho okay I'll pop-up shops
living so I don't think I've ever seen a
pop-up shop on the Upper East Side
I wish it's such as Soho like concept
thank you I can think of the right word
yeah yeah so we'll be there see you
there okay well yeah it's gonna be a big
weekend for you guys it's gonna get your
home and that like you have all your
speaker's charged but I'm also nervous
because tonight I have a birthday dinner
so it's like am I gonna be drunk I don't
know - I want to be drunk will it
elevate it I'm so nervous because
tonight I have like a party and then I
just don't know where I'm gonna be at
midnight you know I know and Janet and
the friends so hopefully a fifty is not
on my level so like I can't deal with
them cuz they don't hurt eating well
unless I like I actually might bring my
earpods to the birthday dinner I'm gonna
wait til tomorrow
what as I get ready yeah I want it but
that's 18 songs that's so very long
album because I'll be looking beautiful
because I'm gonna take a long time to
get ready are we gonna listen to the
whole album at midnight look I got to go
to bed right I want to like not just
listen to the songs I hate listening to
songs like to listen so closely like I
just want to live with this I wish were
in LA we'd get it at 9:00 yeah that's so
true people in all I have it's so good
yeah but then they get everything
spoiled for them like The Bachelor yeah
and they're always upset about it Game
of Thrones is worse cuz you got your
spoilers like Oh Cristina was Nina right
no Game of Thrones spoilers we're like
the actual works yeah yeah Cristina okay
do you think I think it's time because
they think a lot of what we have to talk
about today
you know really ties into everything
we're already you know it's like a lot
of my pre-show chatter bleeds into
stories so we might as well just start
the stories so without further ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and of
course I'd be heartbroken if I didn't
let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by one of our favorite
sponsors actually Jackie's favorite
sponsor roommate
what am the one of my favorite sponsor
which is so crazy right no canal yeah
you don't even drink the brew mate is
really the greatest concept ever it's
really just it's it's a cup what would
you a thermos would you call it it's
yeah an insulated and insulated to drink
beverage holder beverage holder but it
can hold the liquid itself the whole
bottle of wine it's for people who like
like to drink or even don't like to
drink like me but when they drink they
want quality so like if I have a bottle
of wine I'm taking it to a party or
something I want it to stay cold also
it's really for people who like to drink
outside and in these summer days it's
borderline you know I read a statistic
well I was watching shark tank so I
don't read it I just heard it that in
the average can of beer gets cold gets
hot in six minutes
Wow to finish a beer in six minutes
that's awful mate look we hate it when
our drink it's warm before we're
finished it so if you're like us you
will love brew mate they have tons of
designs and styles to choose from
they've got something for everyone I
haven't seen listin one steal one Jackie
has like a millennial pink one would you
say a toasty pink one would you say it's
a millennial I would say it's good
morning Millennials roommate stylish
insulated drink wear is designed to keep
your favorite beverages ice-cold all day
long whatever your taste in beer wine or
spirits brew mate make sure every sip is
the perfect temperature also if you're
lame like you just do Diet Coke to like
die cokes need to be cold as well all
drinks must remain cold
I think Diet Pepsi is due to I'm not
sure because I've never had one but I
think they do too
don't settle for warm alcohol chill out
with your favourite drinks all day long
with brew mate visit brew mate common ad
code Steen's to get 15% off your first
order that's 15% off your first order
when you go to be are you ma te dot-com
/ oh no not / sorry roommate be are you
ma te dot-com and the code is Steen's
ste e + s easy to remember
roommate comm sign-on get drunk with
cold beverages yes get drunk the right
way and by the way I don't get me wrong
there's the wrong way to get drunk there
is I feel like it's also great for
college students like I would have loved
to and also it
like a closed container you know you're
not walking around with a bottle of wine
I wouldn't think it's just your coffee
right I would have loved to like walk
around to parties with an ice-cold wine
I actually did that at reunion so I
finally got to like you know use brew
mate in college but I think of brewery
do you know what I think of no that
scene in clueless where she has that
thermos of coffee for her for the
teacher to share with the other teacher
oh yeah I'm such a dud I packed up my
dad's espresso instead of my tea latte
you know yeah for the remake I'm such a
dead a picnic dad sense tears into my
pink brew mate well anyways okay let's
get right into it because the first
story today's is breaking hearts all
over the world Bethenny Frankel
announces that she is leaving real
houses of New York and personally I'm
not okay
me neither it took a minute for it to
like settle in because it first was just
like okay a housewife leaving that never
really happened so it's kind of crazy
because and she's the one who said
that's never happened in New York that a
housewife has ever left right but her
contract was up and she just decided not
to read up and at first I was like okay
this is news and then it really took a
minute to like sink in and it's like I'm
such a big Bethany fan like she might be
one of my favorite housewives ever and I
enjoy her so much and you know the New
York franchise has been really
lackluster lose us for years but she
really has put it on her back she has
but even when she's like not involved
and she's going through so much just
watching her day-to-day is interesting
and that's that's all nearly impossible
for most housewives they like conjure up
all these like garbage storylines yeah
but like I could watch Bethenny cry in
the back of the car like trying to make
business decisions like for an hour
straight no me too like I actually would
love a Bethany spin-off like just of her
crying but now it's like we're going
through a history's repeating itself
where she's leaving the show what is she
gonna do next is she gonna have her own
show she should have a talk show like
we've been through this you know what I
was so premature when when it all
happened for her last time cuz I didn't
get like the Bethenny obsession back
then I was that young team Jill people
were obsessed with Bethenny like it was
this level but I think now she has so
much going on business-wise that she
doesn't need to be on TV anymore and I
don't and I think she's in a place where
she's trying to do less not take things
out and replace them so not doing the
show will open up her time and her
energy yeah doesn't do another show like
another reality
but I think she's so beyond it she's on
shark tank beyond it but also scarred
yeah because like when she came back two
housewives like she had to like eat [ __ ]
a little bit and she learned her lesson
which was like okay that wasn't the
forum for me housewives really isn't she
said that when she did her one-on-one
with one watcher happens live when she
was coming back to I was like she was
like I don't know if this is a good
thing or a bad thing but I'm a great
housewife yeah and that's what I should
be doing I know and what's so crazy it's
like obviously she has a viable business
so like she doesn't need to be on TV for
money but like I just can't imagine
knowing Bethenny Frankel just as like a
random celebrity not someone like I know
a lot of stuff about and watch her on TV
do you mean yeah I feel that's like
where your sanity starts to become like
an entitlement like I feel entitled to
know everything about Bethenny because I
love her and I've supported her and I
just like want to know her day to day
and literally watch her on a 360 24
hours a day camera but that's not a
logical way of thinking ya know and I'm
truly gonna miss her and New York will
be vastly different without her but I
think she's picking a good time to leave
because even though we were always on
her side she redeemed herself from last
season yep she had a good season this
year everybody's like hearts are with
her you know and she made it through the
storm but now it's over
no cuz past she has a new man she has
like of she's bill she's a life for
herself and it doesn't require her to be
on television of everything to the show
and there's something to be said about
going out on top and not many people can
do it cuz it's so hard to be on top in
general and then when you're on top you
just want to stay right it's like ailing
this is definitely like a really good
move for her it's just like I'm really
sad and I'm really like worried about
the franchise like I actually think she
might have been the glue holding this
random group of women together and I do
think it might be time to clean house
well this doesn't bode well for Tinsley
because at the Reunion Bethenny was like
the only one who was having her back and
the other one who needs to have your
back uh so I definitely think there's
gonna be a shake-up but they went on
cheerio and she said there is new cast
mates they start filming in about a
month or now II know I read on Twitter
that literally they're supposed to start
filming like today they always start
filming like when it's like a little too
cool to be in the Hamptons yet they're
all still there
right because like finally they can film
now right their summers are over so this
will be super interesting these women do
not do well with new housewives like no
Ramona Singer is not interested no but
it's like Real Housewives of
County they've now started to understand
like embracing new talent it's just a
part of the show and I can actually be
hooves you and it behooves the entire
franchise so they've all like now they
really like Bronwyn but they they're
getting it now yeah no it's like change
or get left behind and like Nicky poop
who's just too many new girls yeah and
that's not sustainable no it's not so I
really hope that women are self-aware
enough in New York to like understand
what this means and I hope they all now
like are shaking in their boots a little
like Bethenny's not here like we could
also not be here yeah but I also I hope
they get quality housewives because
Barbara Kaye was not it no it was not it
and you know what's really upsetting
it's like we live in the greatest city
on earth like New York so you want it is
a top five global and cultural and
there's so many people with amazing
interesting backgrounds who are [ __ ]
rich and we're with Barbara Kay and her
house with how Salford to turn the
Hamptons in foreclosure
yeah Real Housewives is an aspirational
show like I want to see some mansions
yeah I completely agree and you can make
the argument that those people don't
want to do the show but there are enough
people who will do the show know it's
really annoying and it's like it's no
longer what it was ten years ago where
it's like the track you drink reality
show like it's big business it's Denise
Richards could do it so can some of
these ladies in New York yeah
so there's that's no excuse none anyway
she posted a really sweet note to
Instagram super long letting us all know
that the the rumors were true and she's
grateful for our stand hood and we're
happy to do it it's just like you don't
know what you have till it's gone cuz
like I just have come to chew that to be
true I just come to not even I just it's
become a part of my life like Bethenny
is a housewife of New York I never even
for one second thought that she ever
wouldn't be so that's why it's so
shocking it's just she's just like been
a stable part of my in my very in stable
life yeah it's I'm really upset and I'm
worried mm-hmm cuz the franchise wasn't
even good but I just loved Bethenny that
I don't even care it wasn't even a good
season no it was awful it's it's scary
but you know never say never honestly
this season of OC is shaping up to be so
good we're episode three and we're in it
I'm really enjoying it like we are in it
to win it
these are happy to me so bless you and
there was a time when it was like why is
this show on the air so everything ebbs
and flows this too shall pass
yeah but I also feel like last year was
it was an important year or they
two new housewives and honestly they
weren't it like at all and like you said
last week they're literally on their own
show and Bronwyn was a great cast
mm-hmm and it made up for the Jeana of
it all yeah I think it's tough to bring
in two new people because then they
latch onto each other and then also the
oh geez don't bring them in so it's like
what are we doing that is literally the
case of Eileen Davidson and Lisa Rinna
they came out together they became best
friends and like they were really like
their own group of friends and then they
eventually brought in like Lisa Rinna I
mean Erika Jayne and it helped the group
but for a while it was like silly they
were just driving from Malibu everyday
together in a limo yeah
which looked so fun which doesn't work
okay next story Taylor Swift was on GMA
this morning woke up so [ __ ] early
and she told CBS News that she is moving
to regain control of her catalog by rear
according masters of prior songs and
then she told Robin Roberts right before
she went on stage that she is recording
in November 2020 so in a year from now
she will legally be allowed via her
contract to rerecord albums one through
five so that doesn't include 1989 which
is very upsetting and reputation which
we just got so I don't I don't really
like either of those things through the
cry actually with like love and out of
the woods remastering which is really
annoying because like when I think of
Taylor be recording her song I think I'm
out of the woods because out of the
woods and this is just a testament to
like how good of a songwriter and
talented artist Taylor Swift is when I
heard out of the woods I'm like I hate
this song is mine I just wanted I know
it said it on the show before this might
be like the fifth time but but it's an
important note and we have a lot of new
toaster so when I heard the song out of
the woods it was a sixth single off of
1989 I was like okay this song is fine
like isn't my favorite no like it's it's
fine like it's a good song and then I
saw it on tour where she completely
redid the the bridge it's like a it's
harmonized it's has a totally different
melody and when I heard it I was like oh
cool this is the best song ever written
it's like she is too different so she
has multiple songs within a song and I
was really looking forward to getting
getting it out of the woods revamp but
since we're not I guess it's fine sure
she's not is in 1989 five no it's number
five yeah yeah six his reputation seven
is love oh my god I'm so sorry I
miscalculated Thank You Margo an hour
fact-checker great okay because I don't
really need a reputation you know it's
just cannot Wow what's a tree news I
know and this was great for her because
that means she doesn't have to put out a
new
ts8 until like 2022 Rick it looks like
we'll get ts7 we'll get a tour then
we'll get like a greatest hits something
recording and then so it said we have at
least four good years with Taylor Swift
yeah and that's exciting for her like
she's she said and she doesn't have to
like bleed out for a while
right and she doesn't have to like be
thirsty well actually Ben was getting
ready while I was laying in bed watching
GMA this morning at the crack of dawn
and he was just watching and then right
when I went to a commercial break it
went to her Capital One commercial and
we were really just trying to compute
how much money she's made before her
album even comes out because here's here
the facts here the statistics that are
just really interesting huge Capital One
partnership her AT&T DirecTV thing is
like over now and they used to be like
the exclusive content like whatever
partner and she'd to do all these weird
AT&T shows but now that's over so she's
so many new media partners and she's not
pigeonholing herself to one company she
has a huge Capital One deal which is a
national commercial and the sponsor of
the tour and they live were the sponsor
of the GMA Central Park show that they
put on this morning she has a huge
partnership with Amazon she performed it
prime day she's an Amazon music
commercial that's a national commercial
everywhere um
and I'm assuming there's gonna be more
to come Spotify and her are releasing
billboards everywhere so that's a huge
Spotify deal for her and she did these
sec spotify secret sessions she's so
Apple music running on the treadmill
felt not any more real there's no
partnership with Apple music and she's
sold almost a million pre-order copies
so without even like really seeing an
album she's sold a million copies so um
he thinks before the oh and then all the
merch so she has had four songs come out
with four merch drops and four singles
so people have bought the single and
bought the merch and there's so much
March each time to music videos well now
another one tonight three music videos
so Mimi is estimating that the entire
pre album press kick business whatever
has estimated around 150 million dollars
that's what I'm gonna say do you think
that's a pharisee yeah yeah I do too
yeah homegirl is a business one woman
Wow look at me so you should sing
business man Wow [ __ ] misogyny being
ingrained in my brain we're gonna
reprogram her you guys yes that's what
emerado said she's being reprogrammed
but there's definitely so genetic
tendencies because that's how she grew
up of course that's how we all grew up
yeah gotta change the system we got to
change the system this is exciting
as you know the resident normal person
here also they start
that's another cocktail fashions that's
not there's nobody there that's a
prestige thing there's not a cent there
there she probably has paid them this is
exciting for normal fans of Taylor Swift
as well
yeah just good news all around just like
old songs you belong with me maybe so
maybe she'll rerecord it and change the
lyrics tomorrow's machines I maybe maybe
she'll give to our versions of songs
right
why what's mashups and stuff exciting
and she does I just hope she gets
creative with it you know yeah I think
she will she's me so [ __ ] busy she's
130 songs but it's like that's fun busy
it's not like you have to write a song
worried about how it's gonna be
perceived well apply it's like you know
these are hits it's gonna slap let's
record like that's fun music making yeah
yeah you know I have to I have to see
something about GMA like it was really
um it was an abomination to TV like it
was such a [ __ ] like I woke up at
like 7:00 to watch and she didn't go on
till 8:30 and like they just kept
teasing and they they wouldn't say when
she was coming and then it was 8:00 and
then was 8:30 like they just kept like
it was clickbait like I know that this
is a big get for him but like just tell
us when she's coming on I watched so
much boring news but actually there was
an interesting story that I think we
should talk about they did the top five
most congested cities in terms of
traffic number five was Boston okay
sorry boss means but that mean that's
why we have so many Boston toaster
listening to the toast number four was
New York lies item number one
number three was DC number two was San
Francisco and number one was LA [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
New York traffic is worse than LA
traffic that's what I have to say so who
made that who wrote that someone from LA
yeah I like people are like bad like
when you sit in traffic in LA like you
are moving slowly albeit but you're
moving no it's like LA it's there's
traffic but you're moving because it's
so big like there's places to move but
you can get off the road like sometimes
in New York you sit on one block one
side street and you can't go anywhere
and you sit there for 30 minutes trying
to go to camp its gridlock its gridlock
oh my god us going to camp toes ice
going to [ __ ] Asbury Park New Jersey
we
the city and we can we left from the
west side so we were taking the tunnel
to get to New Jersey and it took us over
an hour to get from ten blocks from the
tunnel to the tunnel over an hour ten
blocks just sitting there and there was
nowhere to go no it's infuriating
in fear I just don't understand it you
know there was no accident or anything
thank God don't understand it but also I
was watching the traffic news and like
there's so many accidents all the time I
know psycho pedestrian was killed on a
highway this morning at 2:00 in the
morning like why was a pedestrian on a
highway that's so sad it's so sad
terrible terrible well thanks for that
interesting factoids that's what happens
when I watch the news that's like you
read the newspaper I watch Taylor on GMA
and look what you learned somebody of
sharing our class yeah okay next up
Miley Cyrus and Caitlin Carter send
Brody Jenner a joint gift for his 36th
birthday a weed bouquet quote we'd like
to wish you a happy birthday Miley and
Caitlin wrote in their birthday card to
Brody romantic friends Miley and Kaitlyn
sent a joint birthday present to Brody
Jenner on Wednesday pun intended Jenner
who turned 36 on August 21st shared the
gift on his Instagram stories a gift box
for marijuana dispensary Lowell Farms
complete with a weed bouquet Miley and
Caitlyn you guys really stepped it up on
this one Jenner can be heard saying in
the video you know my favorite company
of all time we got the birthday card
attached to the weed bouquet look at
this um this is like such a nice weird
ending to this incredible saga I don't
think it's an ending this is just
another stop on the road and it's nice
and weird and cool that everyone's
getting along except for Liam right so
sad who filed for divorce yesterday
officially but Brody was also spotted
with a girl multiple times and I just
saw pictures of them making out Oh her
story you know what you said heared
about this whole thing because every
time I read the story there is a
baseball player like a super famous one
Jose can say Dada Oh yo Josie and Jose
like I get their names out of like Brody
Jenner spotted out with a baseball
player no I'm gonna get your dad yeah
because I was looking at her Instagram
and she like tagged she he came up so I
don't think it was a coincidence unless
they just met for the first time I don't
remember but I remember I'm pretty sure
I confirm that it was her dad oh my god
you're right okay that makes a lot of
sense Jose can
and Josie could say go that is really
cute names yes I love your name's Jose
okay I'm sorry I miss I was like so
confused I'm like Brody cheddar that's
out with a club where is he yeah no it
was so confusing and then I'm like oh
what a funny coincidence like two people
Josie and Josette she's super cute yeah
beautiful so honestly this like weirdly
seems like a really happy ending for
most of the people involved in this so I
guess who was like the most deserving of
a happy ending but he'll get his yeah he
needs a nice girl from Australia who
likes to you know surf yeah well Margot
yesterday was like huh and I'm like what
she goes Liam filed for divorce Liam
Hemsworth and I'm like oh my I was like
shocked I don't know why I thought she
said Chris and I was like this family's
falling apart
and I was like posted on the toast and
then she was like okay and she's like
being so weird
and then I'm like wait who didn't yeah
and then I walked in and we were like
Liam filed for divorce I was like okay
like that's what you do and there's like
the logical next life and then we were
sorry like I really was upset for a
second because honestly Chris Hemsworth
and Elsa Elsa are really such a
beautiful couple they've like such cute
kids that I'm like it couldn't be it
couldn't be possible yeah was it and it
wasn't crisis averted but you just never
know these days who's gonna fall who do
we ship with Liam Hemsworth these days I
mean always Olivia culpo always what
about Oh Jennifer Lawrence is engaged
right she is um do we see him with like
a movie star with an athlete athlete's
oh I'm gonna be one of the soccer girls
maybe one of the soccer girls I do see
him with um with an actress a fellow is
it makes it easy woman in the biz
yeah yeah I don't know it's something to
think about yeah that's my new thing to
say you know when like you just have
like a phrase that you rely on to end a
sentence no no that's just how I feel
you know I say it's just something think
about that's like my new I feel as
though yeah some people say you know I
realize on the show I say yeah yeah a
lot yep
so I just I'm gonna think about I've got
it I've gotta start working on something
else so you just need to say totally oh
yeah and that's actually a really
annoying way to end a sentence so yeah
will suffice for now so will it's just
I'm gonna think about cuz you know what
it really is something I think about no
you're giving me something to think
everything you say here on the
it's truly just like something to think
about because it's an interesting
factoid
and they're super interesting next story
someone we've never spoken about on this
show but Larry King has been totally
surprised has totally surprised wife
Shaun with divorce filing Larry's suit
Kings soon-to-be ex-wife Shaun was
completely blindsided by his divorce
filing according to pass sources close
to stron who has been married to the
broadcasting legend for nearly 22 often
tumultuous years told us that she first
heard she heard of it when she was
starting to get calls from reporters who
would obtain the divorce papers at the
LA courthouse that's bad
do you reporters she's like wait at the
courthouse in various cities and like
see if any famous people's names come up
in documents yeah TMZ does that like you
know many people filed for divorce a day
in LA you have to sift through tons of
paperwork just to find Larry King and
I'm sure his name is Lawrence King so
you wouldn't know if you were reading it
you know like some guy that is some
interns job and that's why when people
get married in like a random states or
counties and we don't have people there
it goes unknown for a long time oh I
guess so but you can't really get
married in LA without without people
saying about hanging out or without
getting legally married until afterwards
like some people have a ceremony first
and then they get like the marriage
license
perhaps yeah weird I never thought of it
like like that for getting married in
different states but that actually makes
a lot of sense yeah because I remember
there's been a few people who's come out
that they've been like married secretly
cardi B and upset yeah but they don't
say questlove's like I just got confused
they got married somewhere I forgot so
interesting yeah they were married for
like a whole year before anyone ever
knew yeah see celebrities can't keep
things private so I don't really care
about Larry King but insurer signs just
have that's why yeah that that's what's
most interesting he's had seven wives
but he is ancient so there's a lot of
time you know yeah crazy but it's not
when you're 80 that's like 10 years
married what's crazy do you think
someone has like seven wives and so
you're like oh they must all like he's
so short and like you know he's just on
to the next like 22 years you know it's
like two years seven years like it's
like he's not seven Chinese hat he's had
truly seven lines is he still on TV like
that show on CNN I don't think so I was
like I don't know but I don't think so
cuz I've never seen it no me neither
like she'll iconic just like the
background it's but it like so many
movies and TV shows and it's always like
simulated on TV shows where like you can
make someone be on Larry King if you
just put that background right it's it's
a part of Joan Rivers documentary like
she basically put the whole interview up
very cool very cool
I just remembered like getting like only
ever seeing it and grandma let me zoom
like just that's only time I've ever
seen the show yeah I've only ever seen
the show in like other movies and TV
shows right exactly I'm thinking
specifically about um this Lifetime
movie that I watched about a college
porn star at Duke University was putting
herself through college by doing porn
cool and then everyone found out and she
went by Ron she went on all these shows
and then she did a really good job
they splice the questioners from this
girl actually went on to do a lot of
interviews in real life but in the movie
they had they like took Piers Morgan and
then they put her in but it was his real
interview with the real girls yes and
then she said exactly what the girl said
so it it actually they did a pretty good
job in a pretty sure she went on Larry
King you think Piers Morgan gets paid
for that well he hasn't his job is to UM
he's a I'm saying but he says his name
and likeness is being used in a Lifetime
movie no I don't think no I think maybe
the person the people who own the rights
like the network you know they have to
get some licensing yeah but no Piers
Morgan doesn't get paid for that too bad
Piers Morgan so we at least I'm I'm
definitely like him it's time I was I
hated me like says the meanest things
but then sometimes he makes some sense I
think maybe what people think about
ourselves how everyone feels about Piers
Morgan and I like always confuse him
with the guy from Pierce Brosnan no the
dad from what a girl wants he looks so
much longer what they could've the Colin
does a daddy is like a king twin no the
jockey you have the right people yes the
Pride and Prejudice mr. D'Alemberte
Colin Firth Love Actually
he ain't reach King's Speech he's pure
didn't look like I had like they're the
same person when I was growing up I
literally you couldn't pay me to figure
out who was Sandra Bullock and who was
Julia Roberts that's a tough one
yeah and they were just like America's
Sweetheart with big smiles mm-hmm that's
like the Chris is nowadays yes having
time M Evans Pine and Pratt no but I
know Chris Pratt but they're all and we
know him cuz like me I'll do the same
Marv
movies like yeah it's very confusing
it's confusing the prime pine and Pratt
I mean kinda evidence don't get me
started
okay I know we have this conversation
like once a year but also the guy from
the Reese Witherspoon war one of the
Chris's yeah not both no I'm pretty sure
the other one is uh Rosie
huntington-whiteley husband Jason no
he's not as nice Jackie we literally had
this conversation and we looked it up
Jason Statham is not in whatsoever use
for this we call this means war it's war
Jackie I swear on all that is holy he is
not in okay now we have sorry guys it's
like another British guy but Jason Tom
Hardy Tom Hardy oh my god sorry for
everyone who's been watching the chozo
viene because this is the third time
we've had this conversation okay
honestly Tom Brody is so memorable but
why is he so unmemorable in that movie
he's not memorable at all I literally
couldn't pick him on the line honest man
alive show me am I gonna pick him out of
a lineup
oh my god are you for real British men
confuse me no Claude he's he's it oh
yeah he looks vaguely familiar you know
him sort of Wimbledon not a good really
he's in like movies you know like cinema
experience like I just watched like
romantic comedies like Mad Max he
thought I never saw that either I'm
trying to see what Oh This Means War of
course ooh black hawk down crazy movie
never thought oh I don't even know he's
made for movie buffs you know and that's
just not me I'm much more of like a
Netflix original no it's Antonia I movie
oh my god
me and Margot watch I'm gonna say it the
worst movie ever made he was also in
Dunkirk what's the worst movie ever made
I know why yep saw terrible I'm shocked
at Noah Santino's lack of vision because
he should have seen from the beginning
that jungle
whatever this she by the way I talked
about this on the show and I bought I
didn't finish it Jackie we did that's it
was horrendous it was horrendous and so
this weekend I suggested two movies for
you guys to watch because all I do is
watch terrible movies and sometimes
they're good and sometimes they're bad
but like like I said this weekend like
you have to imagine how many actually
bad movies I've watched to get to the
good bad right that was one of them
swiped guys honestly it's so bad that
like you should watch it
is bad acting bad sets bad production
bad casting bad set designed like bad
script bad everything it is awful and
you know what like Noah Centennial of
him he's not good in it either no but he
didn't need to like give his best to
this awful I hope he got paid a lot of
money he definitely didn't but it's like
sometimes with all these you know movies
to the untrained eye they're all the
same
you know swiped and kissing he was he
and kissing no no all the boys all the
boys I love like yes that one is so much
better and it's based on a book but like
he's also in a lot of other Netflix
movies and it's like sir ACR Burgess
awful movie - yeah with the terrible
message that was so weird
like when when she actually kissed him
and he thought he was kissing someone
else I was like this is so [ __ ] up
this is assault yeah it's harassment
yeah it was crazy but at least weak
Christine process yeah but you know what
it really is I was just watching an
episode of lawn on her with this like
bass well team that had like really
terrible hazing and something that
really happened and they did like a
whole investigation into the hazing and
one thing that they did was blindfolding
like one of the new guys on the team and
giving them like a like a girl to give
them a [ __ ] and then it ends up that
it was a like one of the players on the
team who's gay giving like this guy a
[ __ ] and there was like a whole
conversation on the episode like what is
that like is it rape like what it's like
non-consensual but it was consensual cuz
he thought it was a woman and this is
like that that Sierra Burgess was like a
much less scary version of that yeah
laughs that's crazy
one owner is always tackling like heavy
hard-hitting topical issues and I just
saw commercial for the new season and
they do a couple episodes ripped from
the headlines so they have like a Harvey
Weinstein episode I'm really looking
forward to it wow that's exciting
just another Tom Hardy movie that's
really great and then rated is lawless
I've never so probably no one's ever
seen it's like about a prohibition but
Jessica Chastain Tennant and Shia
LaBeouf I believe and it's a great film
so if anyone was looking for an actual
good movie don't watch swiped well that
just reminded me also an actual good
movie that just around me cuz it's
called lawless remember limitless the
Bradley Cooper like translucent pill
thing yeah they made a TV show about it
yeah I don't know how much of
that was but the movie was excellent I
kind of like the movie yeah yeah it was
just it makes you wonder like what would
happen if we had complete access to a
hundred percent of our brain
apparently we only use like five percent
I think I use like one but yeah
and with each time I like with more time
I spend in my phone I'm like losing that
one percent okay I'm not like half a
percent I'll get about yet okay
fit the final story some really sad news
Brazil's Amazon rainforest is burning at
a record rate no one is talking about
this it's so weird why is no until shame
on literally every news outlet cuz I
haven't seen it written up anywhere
except on Twitter yeah but now it's in
CNN fires are raging at a record rate in
Brazil's Amazon rainforest and
scientists warned that it could strike a
devastating blow to the fight against
climate change the fires are burning at
the highest rate since the country Space
Research Center the National Institute
for Space Research INPE began tracking
them in 2013 the center said Tuesday
there have been seven each more than 72
thousand fires in Brazil this year with
more than half in the amazon region
that's more than the 80 percent increase
compared with the same period last year
that's crazy the amazon is often
referred to as the planets lungs
producing 20% of the oxygen in the
Earth's atmosphere god that's so scary
and so bad and I saw somewhere that like
there was so much fog that the Sun
couldn't shine through and it got dark
at 3 p.m.
oh my god I know this is really sad and
like all the wildlife that are dying
like it really makes me want to cry and
like what can you do this is like a
California wildfires and it was helpless
awful feeling yeah two people this is
might be like truly the dumbest question
ever asked do people live in the Amazon
it's just animals I have no idea like
the California wildfires were in like
suburbia yes yeah of their homes you
know it's actually not the dumbest
question because I don't know I don't
think so I don't know that it's super
residential but maybe some people are
there it's just special for like birds
yeah but I don't know I don't know maybe
like we need to all send help all
countries like sends to get those planes
with the powder yeah yeah those Duke
Lewis videos of California like planes
dropping all that it's like the craziest
thing ever
crazy but they got so glad that's over
yeah they got it done they got it done
people are still rebuilding but like I'm
so like don't that wait where we kept
reporting unlike the same fire was like
so awful and it's just going
and then there was three hires yeah it
takes a toll it does makes me it makes
you just like reflecting like one I
talked to a therapist maybe went on talk
space maybe maybe tourists that very
same day send your therapists unlimited
text audio picture or video messages
from anywhere at any time I feel like
like this is kind of revolutionary
because like everything's coming to your
house these days like why can't your
therapist right you know and like your
mental health is the most important
thing in your life might as well get it
on demand and it's like if you go to
therapy you just have like a small
question like you have to wait a whole
week to like spend other money on like
another session like you just need help
with like one quick thing you know yeah
sometimes it's really just like a
five-minute conversation that can like
really fix your day finding the right
therapist doesn't have to be stressful
the talk space matching process takes
your unique preferences into account to
find you someone whose style and
expertise matches your needs and if you
want to switch therapists you can do so
at anytime and no extra cost
there convenient and edu easy to use and
most importantly it's affordable one
month of therapy on the truck space
platform cost about the same amount as a
single face-to-face session best of all
you'll never have this tape never have
to wait week to week to share what's on
your mind that's the best part so not
only does it cost if you're going to
therapy four times a month it costs
literally 75% less and not having to
wait just to talk to someone can be
super helpful cuz also you might forget
like by the time yeah you may feel
better but it's still like ruminating
somewhere yeah and also it's just so
much [ __ ] happens in a week like it's
it's too long to wait talk space is more
than five thousand licensed therapists
we're experts who are experienced in
addressing the challenges we all face to
match you with your perfect therapist
for a fraction of the price of a
traditional therapy go to talk space
calm make sure to use the code toast to
get sixty five dollars off your first
month and show your support for our show
that's toast TOA st to get sixty five
dollars off your first month at talk
space comm member code toast love it
it's love in the oven make a wish I wish
that the Amazon fires would stop also
people are saying that people do live
there and business people live there and
Wars the it's kind of it's populated
along the river right that makes sense
yeah so that's terrible this one to
correct that terrible Oh literally
heartbreaking so justice for then fires
is one of those things that I feel like
in 2020 like we haven't figured out how
to stop a fire I was like the first you
know but it was first
never made I know but it's it's really
like man versus nature you know it's
like we can we can't control it no I
know no you can't control it like you
couldn't there's no way you could like
to stop an earthquake but a fire seems
like it's scientific like you should be
able to contain it yeah no and they can
they have ways but just sometimes it's
bigger than us it's truly just something
to think about for giving me something
to think about
okay so much TV to recap let's jump into
southern charmer you need part one
everyone was looking dazzling dazzling
except I'm a guy I was not in Chelsea's
dress
okay but I'm middle part Kathryn best
she's ever looked best she's ever looked
since she's been on television I loved
her dress I loved her hair I loved her
makeup she looked incredible incredible
I love that they addressed the middle
part when she was in the before they
actually sat down talking with her
understand why she always wears this
high because she wants to that's what
she said yeah it was just super super
interesting their girls have southern
charm I just like so laid-back like
Kathryn really elevates the style but
like they all look beautiful and just
really like simple dresses you know like
they're relatable women yeah and then I
love that Kathryn like brings that extra
bit of drama not mentally literally yeah
did you feel like and he was being like
really mean like in the sense that he
was just like really he's like you want
to hear what these people had to say
about you he was reading so many mean
viewer submission 100% it's like because
he can't say from his mouth but let me
read all the comments of things that I'm
thinking which in certain situations I
was glad for um but he was definitely
just cutting right to the chase yeah you
know sometimes we skirt around an issue
and then if it doesn't you know bear
fruit then he'll be like but you did do
that right but he was just like you did
this what do you have to say yeah it was
almost like they it was like a Q&A like
they covered so much ground they covered
a lot of ground but I felt overall in
this episode like everyone kind of had
each other's backs especially Naomi and
Craig yeah but nobody really had chefs
back no and you know what he needs to
own up and we everyone loves him like
there is a side of him that
is very not nice and I mean the cast
loves him the viewers love him like he
got his own show they have they have
turned a little bit I think they have
but we're always ready to forgive it and
move on and he just really needs to
apologize and go step by step by
everything that he did and make a
commitment to be better and yes and
that's all anyone can do and once like I
liked him so much as a person this
season was a little disappointing as a
fan but all we all we need is like an
apology and just to be better next
season right and we will be okay
I love Craig like I really can tell the
difference with him being on adderall
and not and he's so much more himself
and I just I really love him I love how
much he like totally Cilla's Amy and I
love how much he like just loves and
respects and takes care of Kathryn loves
respects and is just the soothsayer yeah
of the south yeah he's about to sell us
a thousandth pillow we've got to get
some I know like toasty ones I feel like
it's the twistiest material I want oh I
I guess he already sold the thousands
pillow because I filmed a while ago but
I wanted to there were two moments I
really want to talk about and I felt
really bad when Andy and Austin were
like coming for Naomi and matul because
I just a Tammy and Margo memo tool by
the way so hot and literally the nicest
funniest coolest like he was talking all
about his doctor I was showing him you
know some of my will see them and he was
really he really is like a funny
charismatic guy and it just doesn't
translate at all and also like he's not
interested like he is a [ __ ] career
like he's not interested in caring what
America thinks about him he does it
because I think Naomi just wants him on
the show and it's it's her life so I
totally got what she was saying and like
Andy was reading viewer questions like
saying he was controlling like he wasn't
telling her not to eat a peanut like
they're obviously how to program
together they're like diet buddies that
was so stupid and blown out of
proportion Stephen it wasn't like can I
eat this and he was like no she was like
I'm tempted by this and then he reminded
her why she shouldn't which she's not a
prisoner like mad small please like
they're on they're on a program together
obviously and Naomi explained it
perfectly but I feel like we didn't even
need an explanation like if you think
that seeing two minutes of this person
once every four weeks sums up their
relationship like it does it no but all
she was like really like doubling down
on like what the viewers were saying it
was making me sad I think what he was
trying to say I don't think he was
doubling down I think it was like a half
where he was like no that looked really
bad looked really bad knowing that
that's not the case
did you cut out the other part like no
or just she was saying yep it looked bad
it did look bad but that's not the full
story yeah but I said early dead that's
like tough to like defend your man when
he didn't do anything it's just like
it's just not who he is like he's a
[ __ ] doctor
yeah okay let me stop Jason in the
finality by the way that was crazy and
it was crazy and like everyone was aware
that it was crazy like what are you
doing here I guess I could not only does
he not feel he just doesn't come when
they do film yeah well he probably can't
come to most things but also he just
doesn't want to be on TV but I think at
this point like Cameron's really
cemented there's no way that like
anything's gonna be misinterpreted and
now America just like loves them it's
not risky and yeah no it's not but the
other moment I wanted to point out which
was one that I really found to be
incredibly interesting was and he was
reading just some of the the things
people were saying about Cameron
complaining about being a stay-at-home
mom like a lot of people work is not a
choice for them and it's a privilege
that you have that and like you
complaining and she and that's what I
said here on the show of the show and
she totally owned it she's like seeing
myself on TV like I wanted to die like I
know that I'm so privileged and I like I
was mortified and I'm just like there's
such value these days and just like
owning your [ __ ] and like being able to
apologize like nobody does that anymore
so it's like it's so unique when someone
was like oh my god I was so wrong like
that just we're so we used to people
like just like deflecting and defending
themselves owning your [ __ ] there's so
much value in that like I just
appreciated it so much right I'm not
even a mom and I appreciated it yeah
like I'm not a person who would be
begrudged by that because I don't have
kids you know but I'll be like you could
have defended him and like you don't
know until you have kids by the way some
people are like you until you're a
mother like people love to just like
deflect and I just I loved her response
yeah but I also love that like we saw
her real life like okay maybe she could
have had those thoughts and said you
know that may not come off well right he
makes something else up to be my thing
this season but no she's just herself
sometimes it lands sometimes it doesn't
and I appreciate that in my reality TV
stars
can we talk about Catherine I'll watch
it happens live and the fact that she
says she can drink
I thought she couldn't smoke weed or
some art drink alcohol okay so this has
been very confusing and it's
thing that I thought about I don't know
if I've spoken about because she lost
her kids because Thomas made all these
claims against her but she you know was
an alcoholic that she was abusing drugs
bla bla bla and this was back when
Thomas had all the path credibility
those things could have been truer
untrue she was definitely smoking and
drinking but like to the point where she
was but like everyone does no but right
there you can smoke and drink or you can
like smoke drink and be an unfit mother
yeah I don't know what she was actually
doing but Thomas had the power and got
her kids taken away from her maybe it
would have he would have done that even
if she was the perfect person you know
yeah so now it's like she is in a great
place it was never confirmed that she is
an alcoholic that's why she can't drink
she was just made to look a certain way
do you think there was something going
on when she was on watch Robards life
well we talked about it on the show and
I think you said she was being weird and
to me like that's just a now in
hindsight yes something was going on but
at the time I didn't think it was weird
I thought she's just a fidgety person I
know she looks like really nervous and
anxious especially like you're on TV
she's with Patricia like Mitchell ten
pennies they're like that can screw
anyone up he was the bartender like I
think it was Mitchell's fault yeah she
was just thrown off by like how like how
much talent there was in the room how
much talent there was that's very
possible
but I'll soon like really coming for
Catherine because she said one thing
like on watch I'm inside and she was
like who when talking about Austen like
you're gonna get so upset about that bro
chill out but then I first think it's
like okay calm down but first of all
she's like kind of belittling him and
making it like he's not even a part of
the show he's very much a part into it
should they show you I do wasn't is but
what he said is like it feels like you
don't even remember saying that okay and
then when Naomi was making faces about
Craig and Craig was like do you even
remember I mean when Kathryn was making
things about Craig Craig was like do you
even remember saying that right we're
right do you mean they're remembering
yes but it seemed like awesome was like
truly but her like really upset that she
said whoo yeah I agree it was it was an
overreaction but if I didn't talk the
whole time Chelsea she's not yes she's
been pretty low-key this season she's
not really and she'll probably talk
about the Madison stuff and her
boyfriends yes if anyone cares yeah I
love Madison
scared for her next week I know she
looks so beautiful and I just really I'm
feeling conflicted because I do think
she was actually really sorry when she
said the thing that she said because she
like was trying to come for for Shep and
he made her so angry that she just said
the most hurtful thing she could think
of and it took down Danny who was an
innocent bystander but I do think
something's happened after that that
maybe made it worse you know oh I don't
know and they say they're not together
on the show but like they're not not
together so I just they're not saying
they're not putting themselves in a good
position I know I just want them to work
out like they're make it seem like they
live like a different sides of the
tracks like it's just turf war like
there's somebody the war is keeping them
apart he's an American Revolution like
they live literally next door to each
other and why shouldn't they work it out
he's a Redcoat right and she's the blue
the British are coming they're [ __ ]
coming no and also a relationship can't
work when like you've isolated yourself
from all of your friends and nobody
likes to yeah they're like it that's it
just camp but you know who did work out
for Spencer Heidi that's true true it
can't happen
it can't happen they were completely
isolated from everyone and everyone's
like it's so toxic but like is it good
the only ones still together you're
right and they literally have like a
happy [ __ ] life okay I did yeah they
are like changing history love it yeah
okay well it was a great visit two or
three parts I feel - yeah I don't know
they didn't say but I feel like all
that's left to talk about really is
Madison now right and Ashley is she
coming on the reunion with Eliza I don't
know I miss her I actually like she
really grew on me she really were on me
I hope she's back next season and like
more involved she has a new man now I
know who seems more southern charm me so
hopefully they'll get in the mix look
that other guy was like really nice and
cute and like he was always just around
being supportive holding her purse I
agree I wonder what happened I don't
know he's a catch someone in Charleston
chew don't know but he's from like New
Jersey
Donn oh so much in New Jersey should oh
yeah yeah she's crossed the bridge yeah
let me go to Target Oh see okay Oh see
what up oh my god just the longest
conversation ever between Emily and
Jeana like was it just me or did that
when they were sitting on the couch like
it never ended I think like everyone
thought it was gonna be like super
compelling stuff but we did learn that
but what was more interesting than that
was that everyone already knew yeah and
they were all being so surprised last
season me like you're getting two bars
and they were just like beating it out
of her they knew stop no but that's also
like they knew so they're trying to get
her to say I think I like there are a
new friend she's not gonna come out
without your deepest darkest most
embarrassing secret and they can go come
on TV I don't know I just thought if
they only they all could have been a
little kinder no because that's such
[ __ ] like you don't just get
divorced say only incredible things
about this person when like everyone
else knows that there's something else
going on and like I heard what she was
saying she's like I'm gonna come on a TV
show now I'm not gonna be on her like
slandering their dad like I agree I I
understand why she did it now but I also
understand why the women didn't take
that so easily and by the way they never
even brought her to the point of having
to say anything no one brought it up
ready well I wonder why she did bring it
up now obviously it makes things a
little bit more clear from last season
yeah and now I remember I think it was
in the toasters like someone had said
that oh yeah yeah that that was really
sad that they're still dating and she
found a Valentine's Day card like I'm
sure when she found it she thought it
like might have been for her no but the
woman wrote it
no but just was just the friend of the
boy it was in his car so she was mad I
can't I'm really worried about her like
every episode I feel like she's just
deteriorating I'm like an every
testimony looks different and different
and I can't put my finger on it and her
extensions aren't falling out of the
front of her head like I just I'm
worried I - I'm Morgan about her and we
know what gets worse from here and
honestly I'm really feeling sad for
Emily like I feel like she's having such
a bad year like and I really like her
and I think she's like a good mom and
she's like she just wants to do it all
like and that thing with the dance like
it was so sad and so cute like I knew
exactly what she was talking about like
I wanted to do something like Adam my
comfort zone he just like completely
shot me down and someone said a theory
and the toaster said I thought was
really interesting because they're like
really airing their today largely like
more so than last year it's almost like
I feel like they're divorced and like
him being taking the bar it's like he's
not never been in the house like maybe
he moved out me no I don't think they're
divorced like they're definitely not
they're definitely on their way yeah and
that's why it's kind of no-holds-barred
and now she wants to just let everyone
know what's going on so that when they
do get divorced it's not a shot it'll be
a clear there'll be a clear winner I
hope though that if and when she does
get divorce she stays on the show
because I feel like she could have like
a Shannon rebirth like I think this
like this really toxic marriage where
like he just talks down to him like
doesn't make her feel good and like I
think that it really weighs her down and
she's kind of like boring and sad yeah
and I think she's actually like fun and
cool and I think that like in a year
from now if they do get divorced like we
could see fun Emily yeah and actually
could see her and chatted her at new fun
she hadn't could get along I agree I
really I really like her and even last
season like their relationship
definitely had weird elements to it but
it wasn't concerning and I think I even
defended it because like everyone has a
different way of doing things like Jeana
was being annoying in the house they do
have small kids like you know I didn't
think he was like so awful
no but for me the dance the parents not
like saying you're being harassed by
being asked to just get on the phone at
your parents birthday and not
encouraging your wife to do something
like awesome and and special and out of
her comfort zone for you like you're a
piece of [ __ ] now I have a question
at what point you know you're 40 or 50
years old you have kids like your life
is settled you can't pass the bar at
what point do you just like stop right
like you're the man of the house think
you gotta earn the okay you can't you
can't pass the bar do something else
well has he taken it before yes how many
times I'm I don't want to misspeak but I
think he's taken it more than once okay
well if he doesn't have it this time
like with staying in a hotel and being
in the library like no it's weird it's
gonna be enough for me it's some way no
just the show was so fun to watch
because I absolutely adore Shannon
beador and I never a Shannon beador
no wait yeah you don't work but Ubud or
Shannon beador yeah I just really I love
her and I'm just so happy for her and I
love her kids and I love her like lights
paired that conversation she was having
with Bronwen was just so real and raw
and like they definitely had a drink I'm
like they just cried and then just I
love how she's being open now to
everyone and I just think this is the
Shannon beador that David beador fell in
love with and I'm so happy she's back
yeah and that it's on her terms now she
I just like it makes me so happy because
it's just third time taking the bar
according to someone in the comments oh
wow it's a character development that we
haven't fully seen on the show in any
franchise and I think it's something
that so many women go through where you
get divorced the man paid for the water
I don't know that there's water right
the way
gain they just like the feeling of
defeat and then for her to have this
like come back I think it's so amazing
for women everywhere to see like you can
do it no and that's what the housewives
is like I know like Gloria Steinem goes
on watch happens live and says that it's
a detriment to feminists and I think
Gloria Steinem likes the housewives
no she doesn't it's the Kardashians she
doesn't like no she has said that the
that the housewives are not good for
Hammond oh really
yeah and I see how someone could afford
a she does I could see how someone would
perceive it that way but at the same
time like there's so many women who come
on the show like to get divorced or like
they they really like they stay in the
house all day and they cook and they
clean and then they have this like
liberation when they get divorced and
it's like I don't think they ever would
have done it if it weren't for the show
like giving them independent or they
have this liberation when they go on the
show and they're not getting divorced
like melissa gorga has spoken about that
we're like that's what she said about
jennifer yeah jennifer was like home all
day cooking cleaning kids and then she
never had like a group of friend to take
her on a trip nor but even Melissa had
that experience where that was her life
before she went on the show now she's a
businesswoman like she has so much going
on it's changed her relationship with
Joe he's had to like figure out their
new life but like they're doing like
they're better off for it ya know I
think that there's an unspoken like
feminist undertone to the housewives
1,000% 1,000% and it doesn't get spoken
enough about like I would love someone
to write a book about it like I would
actually read it maybe yeah with my
super definitely some things that are
like anti-feminist you know the fighting
and the name-calling and tearing each
other down because that's like what the
show needs in order to sustain but like
if you can ride that wave I think at the
end of the day it's especially in like
Beverly Hills when you know like the
last episode where they're all having
lines just like being happy for each
other and it's like Erika Jayne is the
perfect example of like a woman who
never trusted other women didn't have
friends who were women and like through
the housewives has found a way to like
have female friends and really like
enjoy that which was something that her
life was missing before ya know everyone
just comes on and has different
experiences mm-hmm I totally enjoying
watching OC I know the biggest sounds
like OC sex it doesn't
what is his train I don't know but we're
gonna find out next week right leave
that I love it to be continued moment
that's like actually warrant it like
someone's in the middle of scene Bravo
will be like to be continued it's like
what are we continue
of course the show will continue yeah
till next week right you can technically
end every show with the team it's gonna
be a great to be continued I need to
know what train is it sounds like shits
about to blow up and now we finally know
why Kelly Dodd has turned on town
recently because Tamara brought up train
oh yeah you know what like if it was
this unspoken thing and now Tamra put it
Tamara is the one who put it on TV and
now it's all gonna get aired out I
understand yeah why Kelly's mad I mean
some of the stuff she says and does like
it's tasted too far but I understand why
she turned and that's it good well
that's all we got for you guys thank you
for listening to the morning to us the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to give
this video a thumbs up and subscribe
Roza vailable in the podcast app
anywhere podcasting be found so feel
free to give us a five-start
subscription over there too we love you
guys and we'll see you tomorrow for a
final show of the week
for a lover day
you